what happens now are you building some
kind of case against jimmy
anyone who goes after him is going to
have to come through me
you're not seeing the bigger picture hey
guys pete here today i'm going to do a
preview for better call saul season 6
episode 3. they continue with the
titling convention of a something in a
something wine and roses carrot and
stick and now rock in a hard place
there's one really short teaser for just
the third episode and then a longer one
that was titled this season on better
call saul which likely has clips from
the entire first half of the season i'm
gonna be talking about both of those
looking back at some other teasers that
are out there and things from interviews
and promo photos for season six before i
get into those things which some might
consider to be spoilers i wanted to
address a question first that kept
coming up in the comments of my last
video people were confused about why gus
gave away the safe house's location in
the letter he planted in nachos safe and
then to a lesser extent why mike went
through with putting it there the second
question is less complicated mike likes
nacho and has advocated for his boss to
let him out of the life but that's
secondary to his position in things mike
works for gus and he's a loyal soldier
mike can be sympathetic to nacho's
situation but still acknowledge that
he's in the game he knows that not
following orders could make him a
liability and could get him killed and
he's not willing to go there for a guy
like nacho who knew what he was getting
into the situation with werner
illustrates this perfectly killing him
was probably much harder for mike to do
but at the same time werner knew he was
going to work for a criminal and made
the decision to run away from the
compound on his own where mike's drawing
the line now is with mr varga because
he's a civilian that's why we see him
pocket that id because nacho's father
did nothing to involve himself in this
situation he's an innocent and mike
can't abide him being forced to pay for
his son's mistakes gus's motivations are
somewhat confusing because his plan
isn't that great and they did a pretty
good job of showing how the stress of
that was getting to him in the first two
episodes it appears that gus had planned
to pin lalo's murder on a peruvian gang
things didn't go as planned all the
mercenaries were killed and then
suspicion fell on nacho who survived
with him on the run gus decided to use
him as a fall guy and sent him to this
safe house where he gave him a gun and
tyrus instructed him to shoot anyone who
tried to enter the room they put him on
the second floor and hired a lookout to
make sure he couldn't get away easily
this looked like a situation where he
could strengthen his original story of
who did this while getting rid of this
loose end in the process he put together
the document for nachos safe the bank
transfers make it look like he was
working for the peruvians and the
motel's number gives away his location
he knows balsa will find the envelope
and is hoping that when he sends guys
nacho will be killed in the shootout
that he's been instructed to start when
they get there things don't work out how
gus planned though because nacho notices
the lookout he figures out what gus is
doing and the cousins were disciplined
enough not to kill him they even took
out one of their own guys that was
trying to do that which shows you that
the plan almost worked you might be
wondering why he wouldn't kill nacho
himself since he could potentially give
up information if they catch him alive
and it's not a bad question the thing is
his original plan fell apart and now
he's reacting as things are happening on
the ground bolsa told him that varga was
a rat so if he were to kill him that
would also look suspicious if the cartel
found out he had to weigh the options
and this is the choice he made and it
might turn out to be a bad one that's my
understanding of it it's backed up from
what i've read online and i hope that'll
help you make sense of it now let's
shift to episode 3 and beyond if teasers
and speculation on things that haven't
happened yet sounds like spoilers to you
then this is your chance to leave
the official synopsis for rockin hard
place reads still on the run nacho is
forced to choose where his loyalties lie
jimmy must decide whether he wants to
remain a friend of the cartel after his
reputation is called into question gus
and mike ready the team for a meeting so
the name probably goes along with that
first part about nacho he got away from
the motel but his truck didn't make it
and now he's out there by himself
jimmy's reputation being called into
question is something we'll get into
when we talk about this teaser and then
the idea of gus and mike getting ready
for a meeting there's a few new promo
photos where we see the cousins with
hector away from casa tranchia it looks
like juan balsa is there as well and of
course they're probably meeting with gus
the episode 3 teaser opens with a shot
of mike in his trailer he turns as
someone opens the door but it's dark and
there isn't much else to suggest what's
happening here there are two other shots
with mike one shows victor standing in
front of him somewhere with the
staircase behind him and one at the
chicken farm where he says anyone who
goes after him is going to have to come
through me in this one he's wearing the
same clothes and it looks like it's
right after it cut away as he was giving
gus the phone to talk to nacho you can
see that's who's standing in front of
him and he still has the phone in his
hand and i already touched on where i
think mike is and i do believe he's
talking about papa varga when he says
that they'll have to come through him if
they try to go after him so it looks
like we'll get a chance to see what
develops from there in the next shot you
see kim and jimmy share a kiss which is
in some ways reassuring after what went
down with the kettleman's at sweet
liberty tax services she seemed a little
put off by him giving them the money
after she left but here it looks like
she's holding his tie and is the one who
leaned in to initiate this kiss so at
least in this shot they look to be
pretty happy together although at this
point in the story it's a little harder
to understand what that means he's
wearing a different suit here that you
see in a couple of different shots
across these and in the promo photos for
episode 3. he's wearing it at the end of
this teaser when he hands a stack of
cash to someone in the passenger seat in
his car he says you're not seeing the
bigger picture and there aren't a ton of
context clues here this may tie into
that mention of him deciding whether he
wants to remain a friend of the cartel
in the summary because i'm really not
sure how that fits in with lalo being
south of the border he could be giving
this person his own money back the other
thing i thought it might be connected to
is in the longer trailer we see him
sitting in his car with this device in
his hand and we also see that in one of
the promo photos it looks like it has
some kind of circuitry which is
connected to a dial pad for one of the
old mobile phones that they use at that
time and so maybe he could be buying
this gadget that i don't really know
what it is from this person we'll have
to wait and see next there's a shot of
nacho on the phone a landline in an
undisclosed location asking what happens
now the who the where all of it is a
complete mystery as far as i can tell it
says he's forced to choose where his
loyalties lie but the actual options he
might have are not crystal clear there's
one other nacho shot where it looks like
the cousins found his truck it's cut to
look like he's leveling his gun at them
but it's hard to imagine him doing
anything but running considering there
are way more of them and he knows that
they were trying to bring him in alive
the last and most interesting shot in
this teaser is kim sitting at someone's
desk asking are you building some kind
of case against jimmy this was a
surprise because in the official season
6 trailer it made you think that she was
asking howard this question now we see
that it looks like an ada's office or at
least it's definitely not an hhm office
and you can see the jorge de guzman file
open on the table and there's another
close-up just to make sure you don't
miss it this is likely tied to jimmy
mentioning lalo's name when he was
talking to the detective and ada on that
case i had a lot of comments that
thought jimmy might have let the name
slip on purpose but this came up on the
insider podcast and they said it was
related to him still not being recovered
from his trip through the desert so it
was a mistake
and i thought all of this would come
back up it's not really clear why
they're telling kim about this or what
they actually have on jimmy but it's an
interesting development
i don't think this means that howard
won't also be coming for jimmy though in
the longer this season on trailer you do
hear him say i need to know everything
he does and everyone he talks to i think
there might be a connection with this to
the teaser where you saw howard talking
to jimmy in the boxing gym in that he
says all roads lead back to you talking
to jimmy and there's a third person
there in the final shot many fans
speculated that this might be the same
pi that chuck hired when he was waiting
for jimmy to break into his house and
there is a resemblance even though it's
out of focus all of those things taken
together makes you wonder if that's who
you saw tailing them as they were
driving away from the kettleman's place
that seems to be a pretty good guess and
a lot of the internet talks about it as
if it's already a fact in the official
trailer we heard kim ask jimmy if he
ever felt like he was being followed at
the end of episode 2 we saw that
somebody was doing that and now there's
a possibility that the ada might be on
to him the cartel is always a threat and
that howard will also try to fight back
the last big thing from the longer
teaser were more of these shots of a
dapper looking lalo inside someone's
house or apartment he has a gun with a
silencer and this appears to be the next
step he's going to take in his search
for proof initially i thought this might
be in the u.s but that seems less likely
after seeing the first two episodes it
could be in mexico or it's possible he
could leave the country in an ew
interview when peter gould was asked if
there were any hints he wanted to drop
about the proof that lalo is off to find
he said if fans watched the beginning of
last season carefully lalo is making a
bunch of phone calls and trying to
understand what it is and werner ziegler
was building for gustavo frank and that
would be a definite vulnerability for
the fring organization he needs some
kind of proof that gus is plotting
against the cartel otherwise killing him
while he's making big bucks for donaldio
is going to be a problem for the
salamanca family does that mean he's
going to germany it's hard to say but i
would have never thought twice about
that scene if the showrunner didn't
bring it up so now i'm definitely
thinking that there are a lot of other
minor shots that pop up in these there's
a shot of huel with an unknown character
one of francesca knocking on what looks
like the door to his office at the strip
mall we might be seeing their reunion
pretty soon a couple of nacho and a much
nicer shirt than he had on when he was
running one of these might even be in
gus's trailer at the chicken farm
there's one of howard running from his
car towards a black suv the way that
it's cut it looks like it's outside of
los pollos but if you look closely it
looks like a different parking lot and
at the end we hear kim say i'm saul
goodman i fight for you as she's making
a punching motion which reminded me of a
breaking bad webisode and an old saw
commercial which i could only find a
480p version of because it's so old so
you can check that out i think that's a
good place to leave things let me know
in the comments what you think is going
to happen next what you think about
these teasers what do you see what are
you thinking please like this video if
you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon
you